one that everyone loves is that i have
spiders in my skin
i got my tongue split
i
have tattooed my eyeballs that's cool
right freaks a lot of people out but i
like them
there was never really a time in my life
where i had like this realization or
like epiphany that i wanted to be
covered in tattoos or like heavily
modified it just kind of came to be like
it just happened the first tattoo i got
was i was probably about 12 years old
and it was a home job we just got like a
tattoo machine of our own and started
doodling on ourselves my first
professional tattoo i was probably about
15. a lot of people ask me how many
tattoos i have all up but it's so hard
to
answer that question because like on my
face alone i've probably
had like
30 tattoos
just you know what i mean like like
layers on layers on layers
but it'd definitely be upwards of like
150 200 times that i've had sittings if
those sittings go for eight hours all
those sittings go for 15 minutes
you know it's it's whatever but yeah i
guess my first modification was my
stretched ears
which i started when i was like 11 years
old yeah so they're a bit like calamari
um
delicious
but i think my more like
full-on
uh mods was when i was maybe 17 or 18.
i got some scarification on my face who
doesn't have a bit of slicing kind of
like the sides of my face my forehead
i've had branding so there's like some
indentations and stuff of
all that i've had scarification on like
my jaw so you can see like
the like lines and stuff
uh and i also got my nostrils punched
out so they get like a corkscrew and
kind of like
yeah it's nasty stuff i
have tattooed my eyeballs
so like that's cool right bit
nifty uh freaks a lot of people out but
i like them so that's all that really
matters
you lay down
and
you hold your eyes open
while
the person who's doing the procedure
pretty much gets saline and tattooing
and sucks it up in a syringe
and then
very gently delicately uh kind of
injects it
uh in certain spots of your eye they're
kind of cool
heard a lot a lot of stitches a lot of
pain
had stretches inside my ears very cool
very cool one that everyone loves is
that i have spiders in my skin
everyone like kind of like
wigs out about that
yeah everyone wigs out about that one
these are just silicon implants so it's
just yeah just silicon in the shape of a
spider they just kind of shove in there
i've got like a little baby one in my
thumb everyone's like everyone's like is
that a real spider
i got my tongue split you get a scalpel
you get your tongue
and someone cuts it in half and stitches
it up and then you have like a week of
for me personally
not being able to eat
properly or at all for like two or three
days couldn't take pain medication i
tried even getting like a baby syringe
and like sucking it up in a baby syringe
and trying to get it back like back my
throat wouldn't work i had to sleep
sitting up so i didn't like choke on my
own saliva and blood
and
die
i got my belly butt removed which is
kind of like
very like kyle xy and the whole
procedure behind it is uh
pretty much
cut
around your belly button and in
and the grossest part was that like
during getting it done
the guy was like
do you wanna have a look
and i was like
yeah i wanna have a look
so i like sat up i like i like sat up a
little bit and looked down and he's like
you know yeah you tense your muscles
like tense abs muscles and i pushed and
you could see like
like pretty much like my stomach lining
sort of thing like protruding through
this hole just a little bit no it wasn't
it wasn't like that it was more like
it's like that but like it was kind of
gross so yeah i've had stretches in like
my top lip i had a big stretcher down
here you can see the scar from it
running um horizontally there there was
like a big stone in there
all right and i have my gums tattooed
[Laughter]
yeah
i really haven't paid that much most of
people that have tattooed me or done
most of my work whether like very close
friends of mine so
things for friends you know if i had to
put
like
the industry standard
on it i'm sure you'd be looking upwards
of like 60 000
for everything like modifications and
tattoos included yeah modifications
aren't cheap modifications are expensive
i think your eyes alone are about 1.5
000. yeah being heavily tattooed and
heavily modified definitely
kind of restricts a lot of things you
can do unfortunately
obviously that can be from
going out clubbing with your friends or
trying to use your iphone to
like unlock it with your face which is
not a great time i think for a long time
people have been way too way too focused
on
what other people are doing
you know karen from california the way i
look or the what i do to my body
is never in a million years going to
affect her or her family or anything
like that so i just think it's yeah like
we all we're all guilty of it we all
we're all guilty of passing a little bit
of judgment here and there but i think
in the scale in which people do it now
is just like ridiculous yeah there's
like i guess you could say i regret some
tattoos not just regret i think like i
think there's a difference between
regret and wanting to be perceived
differently i don't know if that makes
sense um wanting to like be able to take
like my daughter to school and stuff and
and not have like her friends freak out
or like other friends parents freak out
and stuff if my daughter ever came to me
uh being of age
uh of like when i roughly started
getting modifications and and heavily
tattooed i don't think i have so much a
problem with tattoos especially
not visible
like
clothing can cover sort of thing
or even like throat and stuff i'm okay
with but i think it's weird when you're
touching the face
the face is a big thing that
can lead to so many
for some people not everyone but for
some people lead to a lot of problems
for yourself
which i probably wouldn't want my
daughter to have to deal with until she
was like a bit older i wish that i
may have not had gone as hectic as i did
on my face yeah so i'm getting laser or
i have been for years pretty much 12
months and i've probably gone over my
full face maybe
like we do in sections but i've probably
gone over the full thing maybe like six
or seven times and it's starting to
really like drop out like
like this is all solid
everything was solid and now it's kind
of really not that like a big
stripes on my chin and stuff
um but yeah it's dropping out quite
nicely i started getting it done
like
the anxiety and stuff i was getting and
i can't i don't know if i can contribute
like if it's mental stuff is a funny
thing to try and pin down but
i like i want to think that a lot of the
anxiety was from just having a face full
of tattoos starting over and having like
a fresh face will be like a really nice
feeling so i'm happy with the way i look
but i'm also happy with
the mentality that in
over the next two years
my face tattoos are gonna become less
and less and less i'm just clearing the
canvas realistically like i can paint
over it again but i'm just clearing the
canvas and you should be able to do
whatever you want with your body and
honestly i've done this the hectic face
tattoos i've done this on that and it's
just like another chapter
in
what i'm doing to myself it's just
clearing part of the canvas that's all
it really is
and it just kept getting worse and
prolonged and i just remember like the
rising tension in the cabin no one was
saying anything no one was screaming or
anything like that
but like
it was palpable you know just the
feeling in the air that like
you know we're all thinking like what
the heck is going on